Ray I can see a slight smile on your
face we don't get that very often uh you
must be feeling quite good about uh this
game and your performance today but it
wasn't easy it was a very tense game how
would you assess it where did you feel
like the critical moments were give us
your story about today's
game um yeah I felt like I got uh you
know a relatively Pleasant position out
of the opening in the sense that I
wasn't really risking anything uh the
first moment that surprised me a little
bit was when he played Bishop B7 really
quickly in Rook A8 yes which I guess
makes some sense I just I don't know for
some reason I didn't expect him to just
start playing on the queen side um at at
that moment just one second can you tell
us why you spend uh almost 50 minutes or
move six rookie
one oh sure um yeah I mean it was pretty
clear if I play Rook e one which I
always play he's going to play the
Marshall and which makes sense like I
probably haven't shown anything against
the Marshall I think probably the last
games I played in classical or a few
years ago probably against Wesley and I
was playing like A4 B4 D4 and just
making a draw so I was thinking okay why
can also play something like D3 or
there's other moves so I could have
played kind of an anti- Marshal but uh I
decided just to play uh with A4 again
and then he didn't play with B4 he
played with Bishop B7 which is also a
normal line and then yeah I went with
this bishop D2 H3 line I think it was
pretty standard Knight d8 was very uh
normal I was trying to remember some of
the theory but couldn't remember too
much and yeah here I wasn't sure if
Knight A3 was actually a good move but
it seemed safe enough to me yep um so
yeah as I was saying after here take
take Bishop B7 I was a bit surprised by
uh and and then we got this position
yeah he played very provocatively the
whole game like Queen
A4 and I don't know just moving his
Pieces away from the King side and
putting his Queen on this like weird
square and then yeah this Knight D7 move
obviously I'm I'm better but I couldn't
find anything
like uh amazing like I suspected yeah
okay I see the computer says I'm much
better I suspected probably a much
better somehow but I wasn't sure how to
actually prove that it's definitely not
I ended up and you did something very
interesting you were uh using this
strategy of repeating the position as
many times as possible before deviating
why did you do
that uh I wanted to get closer to the
time control uh because I was lower on
time I think that was uh pretty clear so
yeah I repeat it here and he couldn't
really deviate I didn't feel like so it
was yeah pretty safe to just repeat and
then um yeah I played it very safe where
I went with B5 basically liquidating and
reaching a position where I have like
zero risk and I should still be probably
slightly better but um he should be
holding it I guess um and
then yeah later
on yeah he brought his Queen back up uh
to A3 again like very aggressive and
then on B2 which was also like I don't
know why he had to play so risky like
here after Queen B2 I was thinking about
if I could play Bishop takes C5 Knight
takes C5 Knight G5 and just start an
attack but I couldn't quite make it
work uh yeah here Knight G5 and uh maybe
Rook B7 like my Rook is always hanging
on on C1 and if Rook C2 he has Queen B1
so I decided to again repeat like with
uh I instead played Rook C2 and then I
was expecting Queen B1 and I was going
to repeat again with Rook C1 yeah and
then try to find um some other way to
continue I'm surprised the advantage is
actually that big I thought he should be
holding it I think this move Knight to
G5 but again this are engine advantages
in general right over theboard this
feels much lower than
that by the way just I mean G I was I
was considering but I didn't realize it
was so strong but yeah I don't I I
really don't understand like yeah I
guess he just completely missed Rook A2
I don't know how to explain Queen A3 I
was trying to figure out what he could
have missed but um uh yeah that was a
very abrupt end to the game um obviously
not expecting that at all what was your
internal reaction when you saw him
putting that Queen on
A3 I was just very confused because I
mean I didn't even consider it at all I
I was just I mean he could have maybe
gone to B7 but I was pretty sure he
would just play Queen B1 more or less
automatically um and yeah then when he
played it I was like looking at him a
bit just trying to figure out if if he
blundered it just by reading his face
but he didn't really react at first but
yeah then then it became clear that um
yeah it was just a a huge blunder well
Ray um a huge blunder but definitely you
will take that full point home tonight
congratulations is a big victory
especially before the rest day any plans
for the rest
day um no no specific plans I mean
overall I'm I'm just happy that uh after
such a disastrous start I'm now
doing uh not super terrible still not
great but um you know much better
playing much better also than I was at
the beginning so just hoping to um get
some rest and keep going tough last
three games I think I have two blacks so
hopefully I can have a decent finish as
well well uh go get your rest go get
your rest day and we'll see you in a
couple of
days our congratulations as well